what are the safe steps to figuring out  how to remove psychiatric medication  many people because of various  circumstances in their life  are just not in a position to stop  taking medications even if it takes them  a year  so just reducing your exposure reducing  the dose because in north america we  have a tendency  to give higher drugs higher doses so  just diminishing by half over time  that is already a big accomplishment  you've reduced your exposure to  something that could  potentially be quite toxic to you maybe  later you want to reduce that again  eventually by another half  and so on there are a few websites that  run by ordinary lay  quote lay people and they have amazing  advice  much better than anything that is  currently available  in any textbook of pharmacology or  psychopharmacology